gymnastics is so hard I just don't want
to be the gym right now glad I haven't
broken a bone yet hopefully I didn't
just jinx myself
it is 6:30 in the morning day one of my
new challenge for BuzzFeed I'm gonna be
training like a gymnast for 30 days and
I am really excited actually and I was a
kid I always watch pneumatics and I
thought it was the coolest thing ever
I just thought Jesus were so strong and
in control of their bodies and that is
just not me I'm also pretty terrified
because I am scared of everything so the
idea of flipping over it kind of
terrifies me no gender I was always
really scared to go on trampolines or
diving boards I had this irrational fear
that I would break my neck or dislocated
elbow or something like that this will
be a little different I'll be training
with Power Harry Paul Ruggieri so I
enlisted the help of Paul Revere II who
is literally one of the best gymnasts in
the world he has his own gym in New York
now where you can train as adults and I
really wanted to try it and I'm an adult
so I figured why not we'll see what
happens over 30 days maybe after this L
try and join the Olympics I just
finished up up in this project where I
did 100 pull-ups a day for 30 days and
if finished that I'm literally in the
best shape of my life so I thought well
if I'm in the best shape of my life and
I really want to be a gymnast and
gymnasts are so strong now's the time to
do it I wasn't really just looking for
physical transformations with like
tighter abs or a butt or bigger
shoulders or whatever I really want to
see how far I could go in gymnastics and
increase my flexibility so I'm working
on my splits and this is as far as I can
go on day one so wish me luck I'm about
to start my tumbling class and I'm
really excited for it but I'm just so
tired
and I don't know how I'm gonna keep up
with this for 30 days and sit out the
major trick that I wanted to learn was a
front handspring and it's actually much
harder than you think
going into it I sort of thought okay you
run and you put your hands down and
somehow your body flips over and you can
land it but there are so many steps to
it and when you're actually trying to do
it your mind sort of goes blank with
everything gymnastics is such like a
mind sport that you have to remember all
the steps but you also have to let
everything go and just trust that your
body is going to do what you needed to
do when I was learning front handspring
we started doing like donkey kicks in
the air and then eventually we build up
enough momentum to flip our bodies are
over and at first you land on your back
and then on your butt and then you try
and leave on your feet there are just so
many things that could go wrong and I
thought about all of them as I was doing
it so it just took me a very very long
time to land but when I did lay in that
front handspring after a while it was
incredible I am finished with day one
just got done with the tumbling class
was really really fun actually I am very
excited to keep going with this one day
is done 29 left is day 2 of the project
I actually feel pretty good I thought it
was gonna be a little more sort i
definitely pushed myself yesterday so
it's not for lack of trying because I
was doing some buddy workouts each day
and because I was actually training like
the competitive athlete this I had to
remind myself that this is literally
their full-time job but for me I already
have a full-time job at BuzzFeed so this
was a complete lifestyle change wake up
and do a workout and then go to work and
then do another workout and then
sometimes another workout on top of that
and I had to convince myself that it was
normal and okay and that my body would
get used to it but I was absolutely
exhausted for that first week
[Music]
my legs are pretty sore from yesterday
is the beginning of day four of the
challenge I am very tired and sore and I
did not want to do it but here we are
just worked on my tumbling for the last
90 minutes feel like I'm not getting any
better I was just basically working on
front handspring this the whole time and
it's could not I just don't understand
it I don't know how to keep my legs
straight and I don't know how to open up
like an arch my back and have my arms I
just don't get it I'm so frustrated with
myself just to work on something for so
long and feel like I'm not really
getting anywhere I know it's only day
four definitely gonna feel it tomorrow
morning when I wake up but don't have
time to be sore because I have to work
out again in the morning during the
second week of the challenge I really
wanted to focus on the front tuck which
is basically just a front flip that was
the scariest thing for me just because I
don't like flipping over and I thought
if I'm gonna get hurt during the
challenge this is exactly how it's gonna
happen just finished day 10 worked a lot
on getting comfortable with being upside
down and worked on front tucks today and
I am not comfortable being upside down
everything in my body is telling me
don't do this so it's so frustrating
because I want to do it and I want to be
good at it but I'm just not comfortable
I just wish I had more progress right
now
day eleven is officially done I just got
done at the domestics gym there was no
like session with the trainer or
anything like that it was just like an
open gym so worked on something I
already knew I was working on my front
handsprings and I was landing them for
the most part which is awesome that's
definitely progress but I'm noticing
that my arms aren't in sync when I'm
leaving the mat so I just need to keep
them together the whole time in like the
same motion just like straight the whole
way need to keep working on it is the
morning of day 14 on to my first workout
of the day and it's legs today so I'm
not super excited but gonna work on
handstands a buncha toots because I
really need to work on them my goal at
the end of this is to do a 10-second
handstand just on my own without the
wall to help me and I don't know if
that's like it possible to do in just a
couple weeks but we're gonna try it and
hopefully I'll be able to do it the
hardest part for me even with the Hansen
was making sure that my back wasn't arch
I would take footage of myself and watch
it repeatedly and just see that there
was a curve in the spine so I needed to
really tighten up and keep a hollow hold
it in my torso one of the things that
Paul taught me was to practice by doing
push-ups you should just make sure that
my elbows are sort of coming in this way
instead of I guess when I do a handstand
my hands are like this but I want to
so that is straight pointing at you is
if not your arms gonna be in and bent
and that's just a lot harder to keep a
straight hold and then a hollow bolt to
it sucked up during the third week of
this challenge I was sort of getting
tired of all the workouts I decided to
change it up a bit so I did a twenty by
five to celebrate my 20 days so I did 20
sets of five reps each
gobble squats and then five pull-ups and
then five push-ups it was also a test
for myself to see how strong I was
getting because I don't think I would
have been able to complete that whole
workout beforehand and then I completed
it in just under an hour which is
absolutely ridiculous pretty tired right
now I'm feeling it but back at the gym
later today
I just finished day 24 I think finished
tumbling classes and it was good it was
with the advanced class so definitely
felt some pressure but yeah we worked on
back handsprings back tucks I worked on
that they worked on other stuff it was
fun I did my first back tuck and I did
it
I did it from the height which was even
scarier and yeah
it was terrifying but I did it I
survived it is day 26 of the challenge
on a Friday and only a couple days left
of the challenge so really really have
to push myself
there's opening tumbling class and I so
don't have an instructor working with me
but I get to work on whatever I'm
comfortable doing on my own so I'll be
trying to do front tucks and front
handsprings pretty much all night
because I want I really want to be able
to land by the end of the project we
would be mad if I can't so
[Music]
that was the best gymnastic class I've
ever had I landed my front handspring
and my front tucks several times I was
talking to one on the trainer's he said
you can't say you officially learned the
skill until you land it three times in a
row
so that was my goal to land the front
tuck at least three times in a row
I don't know I'm like ecstatic right now
I was so worried this morning I was like
there's only like five days left to the
challenge and I don't have anything to
show for it outside of a cartwheel and
round off but now that I landed the
front handspring in the front Thaksin
just wow I'm feeling so much so much
better about this I did it I don't
remember what day it is day 20-something
there's only a few days left in the
challenge I just had a Hansen class and
then right after I had my tumbling class
both were super-fun Hansen class was
very tiring it's pretty much just an
hour shoulder workout but then we had
the tumbling class the instructor was
really impressed with my front tucks so
that we sort of went a layer past that
and we did front hikes which are
basically a front flip but my legs are
straight the whole time I don't know
it's cool to to do new things like that
now I have a new thing for
hopefully I can figure it out before the
challenge is done yeah only a couple
days left
it is day 29 challenge is almost done I
just had my tumbling class and we worked
on round off back to us
[Applause]
back tucks befores but for some reason
we just went right into round off back
tuck so I was feeling pretty adventurous
I guess
[Music]
yeah so I have tomorrow and hopefully
I'll be able to successfully do them
without a spotter
spotter tonight said he wasn't really
doing anything by the end of it he just
had his hand there to make sure I wasn't
enough falling off the track I guess but
yeah he said it was basically all me
which is pretty impressive
one more day it is day 30 I just
finished my tumbling class which means I
am officially done with the challenge
and I don't want it to end I really
really enjoyed it I was getting really
frustrated with myself in the first hour
so I was trying to do two front tucks in
a row I probably did I don't know out of
my first 50 front talks I probably only
landed like three of them I was just
getting so frustrated because I knew the
skill I learned it within the last week
and I'd done it so many times and now I
just like forgot it and then this time
we're not I sort of got it back again
but I couldn't do the two in a row so I
was getting a little upset that I just
took a break and then I came back and I
tried to do my Randolph back tucks
[Music]
yeah I didn't really need a spotter for
those and I'm just I'm kind of proud I
think going into the challenge I really
wanted to learn a roundoff back
handspring but a round off back tuck is
more impressive in my mind because I
don't put my hands on the ground I feel
like it's a harder skill I don't know
I'm just really excited then
sad that the challenge is over and I
want to keep going with it so I went
into the project doing an unattractive
cartwheel and half of a handstand
for like a second and by the time I
finished I was able to do cartwheels
round-offs
front handsprings round off back tuck
front tucks cartwheels on the balance
beam I got a lot more flexible
throughout this challenge too so it
wasn't just a physical transformation
and learning tumbling passes my splits
got a lot better you can tell the before
and after pictures when I first try to
split I had absolutely no idea what I
was doing and in the after picture it's
like much more relaxed and controlled
even though I'm just like trying to hide
the pain of the stretch in my face but I
just got a lot more flexible and in tune
with my body and I fell in love with
gymnastics and with tumbling I want to
keep doing it forever I just think it's
so cool to be able to not do something
and then teach your body to do it yeah
this is a lot of practice I could barely
do a cartwheel when I first started this
thirty days later I'm doing roundoff
back tucks I don't know I keep saying
it's ridiculous but that's because it is
it is literally it's just ridiculous it
takes so much to practice them to learn
and then to master all of these skills
and I just have so much respect for a
gymnast because they're just so strong
and fit and in control of their bodies
and I like have a piece of that now by
training like them for 30 days I'm the
kid who worries about everything and is
scared of everything I'm proud of myself
for doing 300 flips tonight
I do it
you